also have Governor the constitution of
the of New Mexico and the Constitution
of the United States and you're an
attorney do you think you're on solid
constitutional ground here well I'm
we're going to see I mean look I
wouldn't do it if I didn't think I had
the right I have the where is the right
where is the United State of New Mexico
public health it's a suspension it's not
a ban the part the like cynical version
of all of this is she can get away with
anything unless they stop her from
getting away with it we can have
guaranteed rights but they only work the
laws that we have only work if we defend
them but if enough people don't defend
that oh well they told us to stay in our
house again they told us to wear masks
again they told us we can't have guns
again like it only works if we believe
in the system